foreign
if we were to get engaged or married I
would have to move an hour away from my
family because I'm feeling really guilty
about that because I have a brother with
special needs my mom and my brother
really depend on me I think you should
feel really guilty because you're
destroying your family I'm totally
kidding Kim
hello hello
this is John with the Dr John deloney's
show what are you doing
I hope you have survived Thanksgiving
and you are preparing for the next
holiday
boy boy I can't wait my hey my
Thanksgiving was magic it was low
low-key this is our family and another
event another family our family and
another family
and we just chilled I played spike ball
if you haven't played that it's
incredible and you end up diving around
your front yard and there's just ACLS
and hips and elbows flying everywhere so
fun
talk trash with some high school kids it
was just good for my soul hope you had a
good one too many of you did not and
that's why you're here listening to this
show trying to figure out what you're
gonna do next and that's what we're here
for on the greatest mental health
podcast ever if you want to be on this
show
um give me a call
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a s k ask Kelly good Thanksgiving
for you
yeah we had a nice one more doubt to my
in-laws in Alabama
it was good I ate too much food Alabama
is there just banjos that start playing
when you cross the line
kinda okay
sometimes all the radio stations switch
Yeah immediately to
Deliverance
I wasn't going there but I was thinking
bluegrassi but
hitting that's where I was going
all right hey
before you send me your cards and
letters I love Alabama
um
way to go all right let's go to Avery in
New York New York what's up Avery
hi Dr John what's up speaking with you
it's an honor to be speaking out of the
show thank you so much what are you
doing
um so I have a social anxiety as well as
trust issues okay which makes it hard
for me to make friends ah
um but then I get like anxiety about the
anxiety because I start overthinking it
so I want to know like what's the
healthy approach to just like get out of
this uh vicious cycle Loop can I come in
can I go one more
so you have special anxiety so the idea
of being with people is it with crowds
or with groups or just one-on-one is all
of all the interactions just make you
anxious make you uncomfortable
yeah so groups especially but even
one-on-one in the beginning until I like
until I get comfortable with the person
okay so then you start thinking about
you start getting anxious about the
anxiety and then
have you white-knuckled it and just
tried to push on through which makes you
super awkward and off-putting in when
you finally get in the social situations
which makes everybody kind of back up a
little bit and that makes your anxiety
alarms even louder and then it just
starts looping on you
yeah that's true and also I have truck
the truck issues come out where does
that come from I
so it comes from basically my my mom has
bipolar okay so she was like out of the
picture when I was uh
she was like in a in a an award
when I was young like oh so she was
institutionalized okay for for your
whole childhood
so like for like two years from like I
don't know two to like four oh wow okay
and uh
my dad is like old school he's very like
tough so
okay
um
yeah so I'm gonna
in just a few minutes of time we have
here I'm gonna draw a thread it may or
may not be right but it's close enough
for what we need to do to move forward
okay
okay those years zero to four are some
of the most if not the most important
relational years of a young developing
mind and body okay
and what that little child desperately
needs is affirmation skin to skin
contact presence eye contact that is
like I see you and I'm experiencing you
from both mom and yes Dad too okay and
you didn't get that
you should have got it right and I'm
sorry that you didn't get it
trauma has been labeled the things that
happen to you
but trauma is also the things that
should have happened to you that didn't
and so I don't want you to minimize what
a huge deal it is that from two to four
your mom was in a psych ward getting the
help that she needed good for her and
you were left with a
somewhat angry somewhat militant dad
who's just probably trying to keep food
on the table and keep this household
running but there were some critical
relational needs that were missed from
for that little two and four-year-old
little little boy I just wanna I just
want to add also like my whole childhood
even like till now my my mom and dad are
like fighting you know my my dad says
that uh he always tells us that he's
only in the relationship for the kids
sure stuff like that yeah thanks Dad
that's real helpful how old are you now
I'm 24. okay all right so let's just
back out and so we know anxiety is an
alarm system letting us know that we're
not safe or that we're not connected
okay and it becomes Insidious when we
can't get connected because our body
sounds the alarms that connection is
going to hurt us and in your case
relationships have been a weapon your
whole life they've been painful they've
been absent they've been not what they
should have been and so your body has
identified relationships as something
that will hurt you
and yet that's the only thing that will
calm your freaking brain down is true
authentic real connection Fair are you
are you tracking with me yeah okay yeah
I
go ahead on I was gonna say so I don't
want you to think you're broken your
body's actually doing a pretty good job
of taking care of you
because hey the two most important
relationships failed you
and they continue to be a mess
and so why in the world would we trust
anybody else with the inner parts of our
soul and being let's just we're going to
go ahead and label relationships as
threat and we're going to move on with
their lives
see what's happened here so your body's
actually working great it's doing
exactly what it's designed to do
identify threats and protect you from
them
okay and you recognize how
lonely
that is
and your body will avoid stress by
smoking a cigarette
it will take short-term release over
long term this is going to kill you in
the long term so your body's trying to
protect you Moment by moment but being
lonely is is a Cascade of stressors that
are going to kill you in the long term
so you gotta you gotta have to go right
through the middle of this okay
okay how would I do that okay so the
only way to heal from anxiety is to go
right in the middle of it is to walk
right through it the more you avoid it
it actually becomes a self-reinforcing
mechanism that gets stronger the more
you avoid it
so you start to go into a room full of
people your heart rate takes off on you
your thoughts spin up on you start
ruminating really really fast your hands
get sweaty and then you close the door
your body says oh sweet that's how we
keep him out of that room that's how we
keep him safe
and so the next time you try to go in
the room it's going to go even your
heart rate's going to get up even more
and your hands are going to get even
more clammy and you're going to get even
more anxious see what I'm saying because
it learns that oh that works that keeps
them out of that room and so what we
have to do is we have to retrain our
bodies that other people aren't a threat
to us
mom and dad were that happened there's a
period at the end of that sentence
now I get to choose what happens next so
let me ask you this
you you have a group of friends what's
the worst thing that could happen
you say a joke you walk into a room or
crowded room what like let's let's
imagine what's the worst thing that
could happen
and your heart rate should probably be
getting up right now like as you start
to think about it I want you to picture
it
what would happen
I guess someone would like make fun of
me or just uh what would they make fun
of you what would they make fun of you
about
I don't even it doesn't really make
sense it's just that's what I feel I
know let's go through it what would they
make fun of you you got weird hair
no it is um I guess
they wouldn't like what I'm saying or
they would just like snub me something
like that but about what
um
whatever whatever I would say okay you
see how anxiety works it's very vague
and when you try to get down and you
start drilling into okay what is it
what's the things you would say do you
have bad politics do you have I okay
I'll tell you mine I'm super pale like a
vampire Team Edward right
um I've got my teeth aren't sparkly
white
um I used to have acne when I was a kid
so I always thought people were looking
at my teeth and looking at my skin and
looking at my like golly does that guy
ever go out in the sun and I go out in
the sun all the time so that kept me a
little bit of a distance or I was always
awkward I would tell jokes that would be
like not that funny or they were really
really funny but kind of in a crass way
and they're only appropriate for a small
group of friends and not appropriate in
this group or I just say the weird
awkward right so I want you to drill
down with me real quick what is it what
is weird about you what would they point
out and go ah there it is what is it
foreign
I'm trying to think I guess
um I guess let me cut to the chase it's
not it's not there yeah
your body's Chase is protecting you from
ghosts
okay
okay and you might have a political
opinion you might have an opinion on a
world issue you might have a particular
religious belief or a
um any number of things
okay and somebody
is gonna make fun of you they're gonna
ridicule you over it cool
then you're gonna your heart's gonna
still be beating
your blood's still gonna be flowing
through your body you're still gonna be
you
you're still going to be a kind
compassionate 24 year old making your
way through New York
you're still going to have parents that
struggled your whole childhood you're
still good right it's not gonna affect
you they don't get evolved
and so right it's leaning into the facts
over those feelings those feelings are
data and then we're gonna keep going
keep on moving forward most people with
social anxiety have a picture of what
they think is gonna happen
and they have a picture of what
negatively and they have a picture of
how they're gonna feel when they finally
get those friends
and neither of those pictures pictures
are real they're distortions so if they
get around a group of people that love
them and they get home and they still
feel a little bit awkward about the
night and they start replaying some of
the conversations then they think uh
they weren't my really my friends I
don't know what I did wrong and now
they're off to the anxious world right
so right
I want you to practice a couple of
things okay
number one
every time you start to feel anxious
about friends
I want you to pause or you're about to
go to an activity you're about to go to
an event you're going to a work thing or
whatever whenever you feel it
I wanted you to pause take a big deep
breath hold it for three to five seconds
and then I want you to ask yourself this
question huh
what's my body trying to protect me from
oh okay it thinks they're gonna make fun
of me it thinks that they're gonna get
really close to me and then abandon me
for a couple of years
my body is trying to keep me from
getting loved from loving somebody again
because last time I loved
they left
right or yes I've got crooked teeth okay
yes I have acne okay yes my hair is
falling whatever the thing is that
you're worried about with your physical
appearance cool
I'm moving on
and we're going here's what we're
looking for space we're looking for a
gap
between our bodies taken off on us
trying to protect us and then that
action that thing that we're gonna do
next
and we're going to try to extend that
Gap like huh man it is getting fired up
as I walk into this Ballroom or into
this movie theater with a friend or as I
go out on this first date I can
literally feel it
and then when I sit down with that
person I'm gonna say man First Dates
make me anxious
I'm gonna go ahead and just put it on
out there
or I am super weird on first dates I'm
sorry
I'm way better at the date two and three
do you see what I'm saying I'm gonna go
ahead and take the bullets out of my own
anxieties gun so it can't shoot him at
me anymore it's got nothing left
because I've been with a group of guys
yep like what would be the what would be
the well so I would take that those deep
breaths and then what would I what would
I say ask yourself why am I nervous
around these guys do I feel less than
them
do they have bigger muscles than me are
they are they more making more money
than me do they have nicer cars or
apartments than me like what what am I
what why is my body responding as though
I'm not safe I'm in danger
I'm inferior
ask yourself those questions and I have
radically different political beliefs
than my best friends on the world we're
different on almost every metric and we
Razz each other and we give each other a
hard time about it and we make fun of
each other like the whole thing and
there's times that I've left angry and
they've left angry and then we just get
back together the next week or the week
after that
but there's a very few people in my life
to get a vote and the rest of people
don't and if you can't be fully you
around this group of guys cool man
they're just not going to be your gang
they're not going to be for you
does that make sense
what you have to do for the first time
in your life is practice feeling safe
okay
okay and
so so so I just want to recap what
you're saying basically you're telling
me that I should take those deep breaths
think about what do these guys have over
me like why am I not why am I less than
them no no no you're not less than them
why does your body respond as though you
are what is your body trying to protect
you from with these guys this has
nothing to do with them this has
everything to do with you why is my body
trying to protect me
and then there's going to be some times
when your body's like I gotta go home
cool
that alarm's got real loud hey guys I'm
gonna go and cut out tonight I'll see
you later I do that with some regularity
I've got an I've I've got a deep history
with anxiety and when I do that then I
ask man those alarms were loud tonight
what is that about most often in my life
it's because I haven't been taking care
of my body I haven't been sleeping I
haven't been eaten right I haven't been
I've gotten behind at work I've got
laundry piles everywhere I've created a
chaotic environment for myself so I
asked myself why the alarms are so loud
see what I'm saying and every once in a
while I gotta cut out I just cut out
early and you know what my friends who
love me they don't care they're gonna
give me a hard time about it because
they're my friends but that's fine
and the people are like oh my gosh
you're going to bed you're already
leaving what a loser well we're not
gonna be friends so have a good one you
don't need to have a good one and I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna lose a second of
sleep over their opinion because their
opinion doesn't matter to me
you see what I'm saying
yeah you aren't broken my brother you
just have to learn a new set of skills
and that is how do I be in the presence
of relationship and by the way don't use
a group of guys
like I've got to go make friends I gotta
go make friends you gotta be my friend
that is a recipe for you feeling anxious
and they become a tool that you are
using to make yourself feel better and
everybody can feel that
be with people because you're worth
being around
be with people because you want to enjoy
people's company and you want to
have good times with people and share
misery with one another
so I should start with like one-on-one
that's totally up to you man
there's not a right or wrong way to do
it what we're doing whether it's
one-on-one okay dude let's go hang out
um take the pressure off this hey uh Hey
guys let's we're all going to the movies
let's go catch a concert let's go do
whatever let's go down and go bowling or
whatever the thing is I don't know which
I'll do New York
um
let's go do those things and then yeah
I'm gonna go and by the way
almost every time I'm heading out to go
somewhere my body tells me you don't
want to do this
we had a flag football game the other
day dude I won I sat in my car for 20
minutes before I walked outside
it was so fun
by the time it was over but I felt the
alarms and my body's trying to avoid
this thing I am gonna do it and I'm
gonna choose to go out and have a
positive attitude about it and I did it
was a blast and this is 10 or 15 years
of me working through this Avery so this
isn't something that's going to happen
overnight
but find a friend go hang out go just go
get coffee be like hey what's going on
how's your life
um I'm gonna send you the questions for
humans I'm gonna send you guys night I'm
gonna send you a dating pack and I'm
going to send you uh friends so you can
if if there's just a group of dudes
y'all are hanging out you can pull these
things out and your friends are gonna
give you a hard time guys if you if you
pass if you pull out the questions for
humans guys night they're gonna make fun
of you that's fine
that's fine
um if you have mixed couples great
if you're out dating you're like all
right I'm not great at first date so I
got these cards great and if that
person's like oh my gosh what a loser I
don't want to be around you then you've
just saved yourself months of months of
Heartache on the front end because this
is it's not gonna end well right if
someone's gonna just prejudge you that
way but whether it's one person whether
it's a bunch here's what we're doing
we're asking our bodies why are you
trying to take care of us and we're
creating space just a gap between our
body feeling it and then boom we're off
to the races when my thoughts start
going down I can't believe I said that
that was so stupid no no no no no no
I'm not gonna have this conversation it
was a dumb joke I'm moving on with my
life
and we're gonna slowly retrain our
bodies to take control of our thoughts
and of our actions and to let our bodies
know that relationships yeah they can
hurt us
though the only way
peace
safety thanks for your call my brother
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the hell
and how powerless home buyers feel mix
that with the stress of moving and life
change and job change and you've got a
tornado of anxiety fueling one of the
biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the homebuyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement and MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back Jack let's go to
Columbus OH hi oh and talk to Kim what
is up Kim
hey Dr John how are you fantastic how
are you
I'm good awesome what's up
well I'm calling because
um I'm dating this wonderful man oh
gross gross
and we've been dating a little bit over
a year now and with the holidays coming
up I'm really hoping he proposes
oh I hope he does Just For Humanity's
sake but I hope he doesn't just because
you've built this thing up so good
because here's what happened hey if he
doesn't propose you're gonna feel like
he took something from you and you know
what he took from you everything that's
how you're gonna feel and I'm so excited
about this when my friend I had a friend
who went to uh was going in for like an
annual review and thought that they were
getting a raise of like some crazy
amount of money
and instead of the crazy amount they got
like half of that crazy amount which was
still an insane race
but they felt like someone had taken
that other half from them like you stole
this from me anyway I'm so excited for
you
um do you think it's actually gonna
happen are you just trying to to will
this into existence
well he asked me for my ring size the
guy what happened hey you're done with
him he's out forget this dude he should
have been way smoother but I had to
sneak rings from my girlfriend and take
him to the Jewel and be like this is the
size ring she wears
I don't know anyway whatever he's not
very smooth but if he's worth loving
forever then I'll let you have it okay
cool he is all right so okay so what's
your question I'm just talking too much
now what's your question
my question is well
um
okay and so if we were to get engaged or
married I would have to move an hour
away from my family
um the problem is I'm feeling really
guilty about that because I have a 26 or
27 year old brother with special needs
and they my mom and my brother really
depend on me and it should be an
exciting spot but it's just full with
anxiety and what if and
should I mean should I be feeling guilty
about this should I not I just
I think you I think you should feel
really guilty because you're destroying
your family
I'm totally kidding Kim
okay so tell me tell me how
I can't tell you how to feel those your
feelings are just your body trying to
let you know
um there's there's signals for your body
so I can't tell you like you shouldn't
be feeling this or you should be feeling
that what I can tell you is here's how
we're going to process those feelings
how do you you said your parents your
mom and your brother really rely on you
how
um well like I said he's 26 or 27 and he
lives on his own okay and so it was a
transition maybe like um a few years ago
to get him out of my mom's house
and into his own house and the plan was
that my mom and I along with a few other
home health aides who are fantastic by
the way
it was to get him comfortable on his own
and then once he was comfortable with
the other aides we were supposed to
start taking less and less hours fast
forward to two years later I'm still
working full-time helping him out my
mom's still working and the staff we
have now is great but with the shortage
of workers and also he's pretty
particular he's around it's been really
hard to find
other AIDs that match is he autistic I
want to get along with him is he
autistic yes he has autism okay
um I just worked with a lot of folks
with autism so is he
um
well I don't get sidetracked here
is there a chance that this plan y'all
Drew up two years ago was overly
ambitious
and there just needs to be a Reckoning
with reality that needs to happen with
your mom with him with you with
everybody
I mean maybe so okay yes often we get
these plans because we want them to work
out so well right and we especially when
someone struggle with has special needs
um we over we can
we can
over hope that they're going to be able
to figure some things out and it's hard
to read the data back to ourselves in
real time so two years later and you
have not been able to back off the time
investment
two years later you're still not able to
find AIDs that can fully meet his needs
and two years later your mom is still
struggling that tells me that two years
later this idea of him in an autonomous
living situation may not be tenable
it may not be in the cards
right and that's really hard to say out
loud right
yeah it it's really hard but it does
make sense I guess I didn't think about
it because he's been doing better but
then also he hasn't he used to attend a
work program and now he's no longer
attending the work program which means
that we had to find another aid until
that hour for the work program that he
was going to and it just seems like he
just wants to stay home all the time but
the problem is it requires a clown he
can stay home is that fair
yes you can
no I mean
why why in the world would he go to a
work program if he doesn't have to
right
when he had some very strict access to
people's time and he had to go to the
work program he went right
so let me ask you can I ask you a really
hard personal question
yes how much of his care
and how much of the things that you say
are needs for him are actually ways that
you feel like you are contributing to
him and to your mom
meaning how much of his care is about
you versus how much about him
and this is an accusation this is just I
want you to be honest
what do you mean by that
meaning if you just pull you just
if you just extracted yourself and moved
an hour away with your new husband
that may or may not happen by the way
um you just packed up and moved
would his life come crashing to us to a
halt would your mom have to figure out
other alternative arrangements and then
all of a sudden you give it two or three
months after some spits and stops and
starts
and then he's just moved on without you
and that feels as devastating as
watching him struggle
um okay see what's saying
fear is
many more that I would be the cause for
him to no longer be able to live on his
own in an apartment setting and he would
have to go more into a group setting and
you you have not given me any indication
that he's going to do anything other
than have a group situation
right
because right now you're propping him up
right
is that fair
tell me again I don't want to be harsh
but I've spent 20 years having hard
conversations with family members about
young people with special needs
and you just I mean we have to say like
here's the here is the here's the truth
to the situation
why is why do you feel like you have
failed him if he ends up going to a
group home
where you can have direct access Direct
Care he can have Community he can have
um
people who are trained in why do you
feel like you'd be failing him
I don't know I don't know where that
comes from let me ask you a hardware
question why do you feel like when you
have joy
that you're somehow taking something
from him
because I think you're scared to get
married because you're scared to move on
with your life a life that he can't have
and there's a part of you that feels
guilty about that
yeah and you know what now that you said
it out loud that does make a lot of
sense and I think that Gil also comes
from my mom
because they know that she'll be alone
and it feels like I'm moving on not
moving on I'll always be in connection
with my family I'm not gonna you know
fall off the Facebook of the Earth on
them but I
yeah I guess I I feel like they do
better when
I'm I'm just around and I thought with
them I bet that's true I bet they their
life is easier and I bet there's more
joy and I bet
um things just go better when you're
around there's no doubt in my mind
because you're an amazing young woman
and you're You're such you care deeply
for your mom you could deeply for your
brother
the one person you've left out of this
whole equation is Kim
and you've managed to like
piecemeal a romantic relationship
together on the side here
um
in on top of your duties of working
full-time and taking care of your
brother full-time so that your mom could
fill in the blank so that your brother
could fill in the blank all of this is
about propping up a fantasy that's not
real
your mom had a different picture of what
her life would look like and she has a
special needs 26 year old son
you've given her an amazing opportunity
to not have to deal with that
directly but at some point she will
and you're great and your brother who
sounds like he's like a fun loving like
he's a lovely guy he's got a lot of
challenges but he's fun he's cool or you
would want to spend that much time with
him
you had a picture of those people who
sent their kids or their brothers to
those places
and you don't want to be in you see all
this comes back to you
you don't want people to judge you in
the way that you judge other people
right and so I will tell you you're
worth having a really rambunctious
Reckless Love
and you're worthy of getting married and
if you've got to move you gotta move
and also you really need to sit down
with your fiance your maybe fiance and
have the conversation here's what kind
of sister I am
my mom and dad pass he's going to live
in a home in our neighborhood or around
us or my goal is within 10 years I want
to have a house with a back apartment on
it that we can have a nurse so I want
you to know this is the kind of sister I
am
or we're gonna support him financially
because when my mom passes away we're
not going to have any money we're not
going to have she doesn't have a Special
Needs Trust built like we'll be really
sober minded and clear-eyed about these
things
but the idea that you can what you're
going to do is you're going to end up
avoiding guilt for so long you're going
to resent your brother
and you're going to resent your mom and
then you're going to resent you for
feeling resentment over those two people
and your husband's going to present you
for feeling like he's in third place all
the time and your kids are going to
resent because they don't know where you
see what I'm saying choose guilt over
resentment every single time
and do it with dignity and respect
meaning if you just pack up and leave
without a Runway that's pretty not cool
but letting folks know hey we're getting
engaged which means we're going to be
married in the next year which means at
some point I'm going to be moving Mom we
have to have a conversation a very true
and real conversation about transition
because this isn't working
okay is that fair
it is it's just hard tell me tell me why
it's hard
it's hard because I know everyone's
gonna be upset
when did it become your job to make sure
other people weren't upset
because man that's an exhausting role
it's not but oh you said it you said it
you said it it's not your job
okay now I'm also somebody who
um
I believe in taking care of your family
I really do probably more so than is is
makes sense
and I believe in taking care of the
least of these in our communities much
less in our homes okay so your life may
look different you may never get that
Lexus you may be a Camry family forever
because you're saving the money up to
pay for your brother's care or for uh
home health nurse or whatever
you may never have a five bedroom house
on 30 acres and whatever thing you dream
about you may be a three bedroom two
bath house even when you have three kids
like so making peace with some of these
things in the short term
will give you so much peace in the long
term
it's just being honest and intentional
about it all does that make sense
yeah it makes a lot of sense here's
where I would start I would start with a
conversation with your mom
say mom in in 2023 I'm hoping to get
engaged from this knuckleheaded whatever
guy
um I'm hoping to get engaged we need to
have a hard conversation about brother
because his the plan we put in place is
just not working
so we need to plan either he's going to
move back home with you
and we're going to get some AIDS and
nursing help here or we need to start
looking at group homes and we got a year
out
um and you need to have a secondary
conversation with the person who before
they ask you Miriam and and hopefully
you've had this conversation but we're
gonna have a very direct conversation
about hey here's the kind of sister I am
and part of marrying me part of loving
me forever
is
um I'm a sister who takes care of her
brother when he can't take care of
himself
and we're gonna be very honest about the
finances we're going to be very honest
about our boundaries and
most important you got to put your
oxygen mask on first Kim
taking care of you isn't selfish
taking care of you isn't a somehow a
violation of your mom's love or your
brother's love
you take care of Kim
you make sure Kim has great
relationships and that Kim's body is
taken care of with good food and with
sleep and with exercise you take care of
you you got good a good job so that
you've got something firm that you can
anchor into and repel off the side and
then take care of the other people in
your life
otherwise man you find yourself just
flying in the wind like a kite trying to
take care of everybody all the time
and that's not sustainable and it ends
up in ashes every time
or you end up 58 years old and you're
bitter and you're upset and you resent
and you look back on your life and say
yeah
I don't want that for you I want that
for your family I want that for your
brother I don't want that for anybody
so let's go all the way back to the to
the beginning here and say let's have
some hard conversation
foreign
let's be honest about am I doing this
for me or am I doing this for my brother
and let's be honest about what our
marriage is going to look like and when
you get engaged call me call me we'll do
a big announcement here on the show
because I'm excited for you it's gonna
be thank you for trusting us and um for
walking with me Kim uh good luck to you
we'll talk to you soon we'll be right
back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor betterhelp let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist at under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back let's go to Ben in
Choi tone in Chicago what's up Ben
all right
excellent what's up man how can I help
all right so a lot of context here I'll
try to get through as much as I can but
my fiance who I'll call my wife for the
call just because by the time this airs
we'll be married in a couple weeks from
now and it's pure syllable so it makes
it easier for both of us
um congratulations yeah thank you we got
it home about nine months ago and it's
our first home that we've ever had so
obviously when you get a new home
there's a lot you can read about there's
a lot you can learn but there's a lot
that you don't know and you learn a lot
of the first time home buyer lessons
and unfortunately one of those lessons
recently came up so
uh last week I was about 40 miles away
trained boxing at my old gym uh the wife
was at home and a couple blocks away
from us there's like a commercial
district with a vape shop and that shop
had gotten shot up there about seven or
eight shots that were fired uh gun
unplug the scene no one's really sure
where they went but obviously from my
home you could hear the gunshots you
could then have a see how the cops come
all the cop cars were within a view and
because he had put the scene the cops
were running around looking through all
the yards including hours to see if they
could find a gunman
so I wasn't aware that this was
happening as it was happening because I
was at the gym about 40 miles away my
phone was in my bag because I'm
obviously not checking my phone while
I'm training
and when I finished up checked my phone
saw that my wife had dealt with all this
and was very rattled by it and so it
sort of was the situation where for her
she she has a lot of concerns where she
felt unsafe I was pretty sure just based
on what a team on it but she wasn't in
any danger sure especially not by the
time they had heard about it so I wasn't
as concerned about that at the point at
that point but I did feel as though
having a house for nine months that I'd
really miss an opportunity to really do
my job and do my part is kind of the man
of the house and really help protect the
house have a plan in place in case
anything happens so she knew what to do
or if I was there I would know exactly
what to do
um to actually have like the right
equipment if needed to protect ourselves
because at the moment we are currently
unarmed really all we really have is
pepper spray and some kitchen knives you
say the right equipment like get a bunch
of guns
um I don't know if they need a bunch
necessarily but guns are definitely on
that list yeah part of your equipment
the way the way you said equipment I was
thinking like we're gonna get some rakes
and a shovel and a pitch for it uh but
you're talking about getting a gun okay
yeah okay yeah so so I'm pretty familiar
with a lot of like combat stuff like as
I kind of headed there like I was doing
boxing like I've been in Combat Sports
for a while and as much as I would love
to just handle everything hand to hand I
feel like that's what that's what I do
and you can use Elite Sports necessary
uh the most important thing in a fight
is range and there is nothing but a
range of that gun you could take the
scariest guy say Mike Tyson ask me if
I'd fight him for a million dollars that
they know asked me if I played him from
50 yards away with a gun in my hand and
he has none I'd probably win that fight
because that's effectively
the Tower of one of those tools and so
if somebody is coming to my home to do
harm and has one of them and I don't
um it's potentially gonna be a very bad
day not just for me but for my family
and especially if I'm not home and
I'm not there to protect
so having that scared to me it just kind
of reinforces that it would be a very
wise move to have a weapon uh if needed
um the odds of it being necessary aren't
incredibly high but in the event that it
does happen it would be very important
to have
uh but that's where the problem begins
so
um my wife uh comes from a left-wing
background her family's very left-wing
and she's kind of got like a visceral
fear of having a gun like just doesn't
it's not so much like
like it to her it's like the idea of
having a gun in her home is just that
she's very uncomfortable with not only
because of the fact that the gun is a
practically a death machine but also
because
like actually seeing it sort of like it
tells you that there is a potential for
harm out there is that
back on maybe needed one day so she's
incredibly uncomfortable with it so it
puts me in a spot where if I feel like
it's my job to protect a home
I have to decide do I if I'm going to
look a mentor and obviously the correct
answer here is to lay out a great case
where she she relents and says okay
this is the right move and I'm on board
with it but if I'm not able to do that
because it's going to be a lot of work
that's going to be needed for that do I
either a
go with her wishes and not get the gun
and we just don't have it or B
potentially end up in a situation where
the gun would have been a thing that
would have saved us but we didn't get it
because I went against my better
judgment and then something really bad
happens
all right let me hop in here
um
foreign
get rid of the left wing right wing
framing okay all of us grew up in homes
that give us particular strengths and
particular baggage that we bring into
the home that we get married we're
creating on our own okay so I don't want
her to I don't want you to settle her
and I don't want her to settle herself
with well I grew up in this Super Rat
Wing home and we were pew pew or this
super left-wing home and we didn't I
don't want any of that I would rather
her take ownership of how she feels
right now and you take ownership of how
you feel right now in her home
in the home that she is creating with
you
um she does not feel comfortable having
a gun in your home in the home that you
are creating with her you don't feel
comfortable not having a gun in your
home okay that let's frame let's start
it there because it keeps all the
baggage and all the smoke and it keeps
all that out of it because all of us
regardless of the homes we grew up in we
have to make choices about the homes
that we are going to create for
ourselves Okay so
I'm gonna back all the way out of this
thing and then I'll answer your very
specific question okay is that cool yeah
you are feeling what you are feeling has
nothing to do with guns
okay you are feeling something terrible
and beautiful and terrifying all at the
same time can I tell you what it is
it's love
and the only way love works is if
somebody's vulnerable
somebody said you could hurt me and they
say and you could hurt me and that's how
we're gonna connect
okay it's taking the covers off the
plugs and actually
doing the scary thing of plugging in
okay
and what you were coming face to face
with
when you got done boxing right and I
trained for years like it feels good and
all hardcore and there's a very you know
what model my training all my years of
training and I train with people who are
in the UFC I train with all kind of
crazy
the years of training
a hundred percent of the time I will
walk away from a fight that's what I got
for my training I'm gonna walk away it's
not worth it and I don't know who's got
a who's gonna smash me in the head with
a hammer I don't know who's got a gun
point on me I'm walking away
your wife is well okay well knock your
lights out because I know my wife so
y'all have a great day I'm out of here
right so all that what you've come face
to face with is
you're not going to be able to protect
her all the time
and there's gonna come moments whether
it's in the car whether it's an office
mate whether it's a boss who's a jerk
whether it's her dad whether who her
older brother who knows whatever it is
you can't be everywhere all the time
and this is beyond the gun conversation
this is something you have to make peace
with this idea that I'm married or so I
got a protector
I want you to re-examine that
you do need to have a plan and that was
a good thing that came out of this
showing to sit down and say whoa what
are we going to do
right same as the first time something
catches on fire in a new in a in a
newlyweds new home and they're like oh
we don't have a fire drill like what do
we do
um or just sit down and do a will
together like who's gonna get the dog
and the kids when we die right
um those are all important so glad
you'll have a plan and part of your plan
might be having a gun great but above
that
there's something powerful that you need
to absorb
which is you cannot be everywhere all
the time for her 24 7 365. it's
impossible and that is a burden you are
putting on yourself that's going to make
you insane
it's going to make you mad okay if you
live in a home that is simply unsafe do
whatever you got to do to move
if you happen to be in a house where
there's a crime committed a couple of
blocks over and the police came and it
was unnerving yeah that's unnerving man
it's wild it's really unnerving
um that's something to absorb and feel
and then put that into your plan so is
are you tracking with me so far
yeah it's scary as hell to think
somebody can hurt my wife and I'm not
there is that true
yeah
yeah I mean I understand I can't be
there all the time but I guess part of
me is just like if I'm not there then I
just want her to have the best chance
possible and there you go there you go
to a better chance that there was a
weapon I've been if there wasn't that's
that's that's
uh potentially potentially
um
so answering beneath that
creating a safe environment for your
family we're gonna have to there'll be
debates on what the word safe means in
the comments of this thing I know
um if your wife tells you I can't sleep
if there's a gun in this house at this
moment I would recommend not overriding
her right now that doesn't that doesn't
sound like a loving move or a safe
overall move okay
um I would here's what I would do I
would create a what would we do plan
with your wife
and let's sit down and have some fun
with it like it may be invite a couple
of your neighbors over like what would
we do if somebody showed up and started
filling the blank banging on the door
are we gonna answer the door we're gonna
call 9-1-1 like what would we do and
let's go through some of those things we
I live out in the country man
and my wife and I have had those
conversations and uh who do we call
where would we go we've talked to my
kids hey if I ever fall off a ladder
while you're here here's where you go
you're gonna go down the hill you're
gonna go across the creek to this guy's
house and so have that plan that's
awesome
um the second thing is I would invite
your neighbors over to your house
and y'all have an open conversation get
to know their names
okay that's gonna give your wife peace
that she is not isolated and maybe
having uh your neighbor's name or two or
three people she could call if something
sets off is going to be much more of a
gift than knowing there's a John Wick
gun in the drawer back there okay
Okay the third thing is if it's possible
and this sounds so cheesy and I know but
my dad was a cop so uh if you have a
conversation with the police uh invite
them over or have somebody go visit have
somebody swing by and just to develop a
relationship with them get the crime
stats for your area know how safe it is
where you live right that could be a
possible thing so let's get to the gun
part I am a
my dad was a homicide detective a SWAT
guy and I'm a Texan so I've got enough
guns in my house okay also my wife grew
up in Texas she was a competitive
shooter and she hates him she doesn't
like him
okay
um she's more of a statistician than me
and just looks at the data that more
people get hurt with their own guns than
they actually fight off Intruders
um and I don't know if that data is true
but that's it floats around out there so
here's what I would recommend
sit down with your wife and say hey
would you take a class with me
would you at least go to a range and try
and she might say absolutely not I will
not do that
okay
okay
um chances are she will
would you take it it would make me feel
more secure if we just went to took a
class together
or would you feel more safe taking a
shotgun class which I think is a better
home defense weapon than a 45 or
whatever thing would
um
would you be willing to go do that with
me
I'm gonna take a class
I want to really know what I'm doing and
I want to know how this stuff works and
by the way even if you've done it your
whole life
I'm going to take a course
I would love it if you joined me
in that way it's much less I watched a
lot of movies and it's a lot more
I'm going to get trained on how to take
care of my family and keep everybody
safe
does that make sense
yeah that's what was the idea around her
I guess just the idea of being in the
presence of one it's kind of difficult
but absolutely
the more we talk about I think she'll
move on a little bit more we both have
the same goal we both wanted to keep the
family safe and obviously we don't have
kids yet but that's when we want to get
started on soon so yeah I think we have
the same goal as just how would you get
there I think taking the class
I think there's something to be gained
by taking a class
um
and
you can think about this all day long
it's not until you actually experience
it that there's any sort of
transformation I can talk about gun
safety all day long with my kids
um it's a very big deal to me that they
know exactly how these things work and
why they're so dangerous and why they're
to be revered and why they are very
specific tools for very specific moments
um and so
I put I'm very intentional with my kids
I don't want it to be some Dragon
somewhere that they call upon thinking
because they watch some movies right I
want them to actually have seen it and
felt it and smelled it right smelt it
and I want them to have experienced all
of the the whole process and now I've
got a 12 year old little boy that is in
absolute reverence
he handles a weapon in my presence
better than adults I'm with
it's very very impressive but it's
through years of just training right and
High High High intentionality
um and so I tell you to tell you I think
a class just talking about like yeah
yeah man that's not gonna that's not
gonna move the needle on the safety
conversation
actually saying hey I'm gonna go take a
class because I want to get good at this
I want to be very competent in that and
what you're going to find is very
similar to
um very similar to your boxing training
your martial arts training
I was really Cavalier my man really
Cavalier
it was one of the first guys in Texas to
get the CHL when that was a thing and a
real Cavalier about the whole thing and
then I started going into homes and
helping police officers clean up suicide
scenes
I started going into homes to tell
mothers that their kids have been shot
and killed
I started running around I had a patrol
car that I went on patrol
and I got to see some things that really
changed my perspective on that similar
to I trained MMA and boxing all that
stuff
and I ended up fighting I ended up
walking I made me an infinitely more
peaceful guy
became very very able to take care of
myself which empowered me to then walk
away and it was when I got out of the
movies and started showing up to these
homes
and cleaning up scenes that will haunt
me for the rest of my life that I made
peace with oh man I'm gonna do
everything in my power
to create a safe home environment that
doesn't include
first offense right
because the reality of how that plays
out is gnarly now
can I take care of myself you better
believe it yes
I've trained and I still train
but I do those things so I don't have to
and I hope that that makes sense
I hope that makes sense
um
my promise to you is if y'all just ran
out today and bought a gun and put in
your house your wife would not feel
safer and statistically speaking y'all
wouldn't be quote unquote safer
if y'all go take classes and you learn
what to do and you have a plan of what
happens if somebody knocks on the door
if somebody beats the door and somebody
kicks in your car window whatever
now we've got a plan that we've
practiced that's where safety comes from
that's when your body goes okay we know
what to do
we know what to do so that's my
recommendation my brother thank you so
much for trusting me with a call good
luck with your wedding hope everything
goes awesome and hope uh hope she still
wants to marry you after nine months of
living with you just kidding hope she I
hope it all works out great man and
thanks for calling thanks for calling um
this is a hard conversation but I
appreciate your trust we'll be right
back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show
one of the greatest bands of all time I
love them love them Green Day and I
guess since I mentioned gun in the last
episode or the last thing Kelly pulled
up they're hit 21 guns and it goes like
this
do you know what's worth fighting for
when it's not worth dying for does it
take your breath away and you feel
yourself suffocating does the pain weigh
out the pride
and you look for a place to hide did
someone break your heart inside you're
in Ruins one 21 Guns lay down your arms
and give up the fight won 21 Guns throw
up your arms into the sky you and I when
you're at the end of the road and you
lost all sense of control and your
thoughts of taking their toll when your
mind breaks the spirit of your soul and
your faith walks on broken glass and The
Hangover doesn't pass
Throw your arms up into the sky it's
just you and I we'll see you soon
[Music]